did you sign something so that Manny
could switch to French I did you knew
that I wanted him to learn in Spanish I
also know you can't force a kid to be
interested in something that he's not
that's why I have a picture of Mitchell
and his prom date shaking hands it would
be nice for someone to care what I think
for a change you should also know that I
hired a new swimming instructor but
don't worry she's got the same broad
shoulders plus a mustache so all this is
because you're jealous
I can believe that you're being so
infrared what is the word selfish
pig-headed really her words not mine do
you know how frustrating it is to have
to translate everything in my head
before I say it to have people laughing
my face because I'm struggling to find
the words
just try talking in my shoes from one
mile I think you might I know what I
meant to mean
do you even know how smart I am in
Spanish
course you don't
for once it would be nice to speak to
someone in my own language in my own
home
but I'm sorry I let Manny switch over to
French without consulting you I didn't
think how it must be for you having to
speak English all the time you have no
idea anyway I just wanted to tell you I
hired a tutor back man he's not gonna
like that he's too much into his French
thing the tutor's not for Manny it's for
me
foreign
[Music]